today on the matt walsh show a school in
new york encourages its white students
to be
white traders and white abolitionists
we'll talk about how
this is only one of the ways in which
our culture instills
self-loathing in people especially
children and in our five headlines the
media starts to update its reporting on
the
on the death of officer brian siknik the
update is that their original reporting
was
absolute bunk also bill gates tells us
plebes that we're going to have to stop
eating meat
so says him and for our daily
cancellation we'll discuss the story of
the father
who sent out a few bad tweets and then
ended up with child protective services
showing up at his house because of it
all of that and much more today on the
matt wall show
[Applause]
first i want to tell you something about
our friends over at lifelock look
there's there's nothing more important
right now than making sure that you
protect your online data that's
especially the case
right now there's a text message scam
claiming to give away
a free year of netflix that's going
around right now if you receive a text
message like this
uh don't respond don't click the link
it's one of those things that seems too
good to be true it is to it is too good
to be true
it's a scammer trying to get you to log
into a fake website to steal your
information and your credit card
it's why it's so important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet
in an instant a cyber criminal can harm
what's yours your finances your credit
your reputation
that's why it's so great that there's
lifelock light flock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats
uh so many different things like for
example if your social security number
is for sale on the dark web
many many things that you you won't be
able to detect on your own
you can check your credit score you can
uh hopefully keep track of your
bank account information your credit
card statements and all of that but
there's a lot more
to protecting your identity that you're
not going to be able to do and that's
why you need
lifelock if they detect that your
information has potentially been
compromised
they're going to send you an alert and
they're going to take care of it it is
unfortunately very easy for a bad guy to
steal your information and that's why
you just need lifelock
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's
yours yours with lifelock identity theft
protection join now and save up to 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off well maybe you've
noticed i've made it a habit to base
monologues around the reporting of chris
ruffo
who's the city journal writer um does a
lot of reporting on critical race theory
and other things
but the reason why i base a lot of my
monologues around him is that he's doing
some of the most important reporting in
media for my money
um granted the most important reporting
in media is kind of like talking about
the
the cleanest highway rest stop bathrooms
in new jersey
kind of a low bar but in this case it
really is important so here's his latest
um he says quote the principal of east
side community school in new york sent
white parents this quote tool for action
which tells them that they must become
white traders and then advocates for
full white abolition
this is the new language of public
education okay white abolition white
traders
the federalist uh also has an article
about this they have more information
they say that the graphic also appears
to have been produced and dispersed by
the slow
factory foundation a progressive climate
and race action group in
june of last year shortly after the
death of george floyd the organization
which claims it is devoted to
dismantling colonial systems of
oppression
and promoting systemic change towards
regenerative
social and environmental systems also
often advocates for equity centered
education focused on creating and
delivering resources about power
structures
and historical social context as a key
driver of any topic
so this is uh and this is a group that
is now giving material to schools that
the schools then
is then sending to parents and using in
their classrooms presumably
uh continues some of the group's
initiatives include their study hall
conference series devoted to using
fashion
as a medium for social and environmental
change
and they're sponsored by many big name
donors including adidas tesla
youtube ted
other other things as well so this is a
far left organization
and this is what they're putting out and
now this school is using it as for the
graphic itself
it says this is what they're telling the
parents
there is a regime of whiteness and there
are action-oriented white identities
people who identify with whiteness are
one of these
it's about time we build an ethno
ethnography of whiteness
since white people have been the ones
writing about and governing others
all right if that makes sense which
which it doesn't
but then there's kind of the
illustration to maybe help us make a
little bit more sense of it
we're given sort of a dial which goes
from red to green
showing us the different white
identities
all of the white identities are negative
okay so they're all framed in a negative
way
and you wouldn't really want to be any
of them but if you're white then you
have to be one of them at least
according to the people promoting this
stuff
and if you have to be one then you need
to be in the green is what we're being
told so here are the white identities
let me uh let me read them to you let me
pull them up
the white identities will go from red to
green so from uh from bad to worse or
rather from from worse to
to not as bad but still bad okay um
number one white supremacist clearly
marked white society that preserves
names and values
white superiority white voyeurism
wouldn't challenge a white supremacist
desires non-whiteness because it's
interesting
pleasurable seeks to control the
consumption and appropriation of
non-whiteness
fascination with culture example
consuming black culture without the
burden of blackness
okay so uh i guess for example a white
person who listens to rap music is a
white
voyer all right uh white privilege
that's the third identity may critique
supremacy
but a deep investment in questions of
fairness equality
uh under the normalization of whiteness
and the white rule
sworn goal of diversity okay so this is
this is actually most white liberals
they're not even in the green yet
they're they're just
according to to this they are only
slightly above
white supremacist these are the white
people that are going around talking
about diversity and all this kind of
stuff
and apparently that is that that's for
coming from a place of privilege
uh number four white benefit sympathetic
to a set of issues but only privately
won't speak slash act and solidarity
publicly because benefiting through
whiteness
in public then there's white
confessional this is another white
identity
you could be a white confessional if you
want what that means is that there's
some exposure of whiteness taking place
but as a way of being accountable to poc
after
seeking validation from poc people of
color
white critical take so that now we're
getting
um let's see let's look at the dial
again
all right white privilege you're
basically saying most liberals most
white liberals are back in the white
privilege they're they're all they're
kind of orangish but they're still sort
of in the red
um now we're getting to white critical
now we're getting into the green
so now we're getting closer to where the
uh
the the race hustlers want you to be
white critical take on board critiques
of whiteness and invest in exposing
marking the white regime refuses to be
complicit with the regime
whiteness speaking back to whiteness
then seven white trader
now we're really getting there actively
refuses complicity
names what's going on intention is to
subvert while authority
white authority and tell the truth at
whatever costs need them to dismantle
institutions and then finally
this is where they want everyone to be
if you're white a white abolitionist
this is number eight this is where
you're firmly in the green
and a white abolitionist is changing
institutions dismantling whiteness
and not allowing whiteness to reassert
itself
all right this is of course
racist in the extreme uh
there's probably no reason to belabor
that point those who know it's racist
don't need it explained to them
those who don't recognize it as racist
immediately are hopeless anyway
or at least they're going to require a
much longer explanation and a much
longer argument than i can provide here
so instead of talking about the fact
that this is absurdly racist which it
obviously is
and that this is a form of of racism
that is widespread
indeed systemic in our culture
instead of talking about that i'd like
to pull back and take a kind of
panoramic
view of the situation if i could because
this is just
one way that self-loathing is instilled
in the population especially in children
yeah this was this was given to parents
of course uh because this is the message
that they're sending to everybody
but only imagine what the kids in school
if the parents are being told this
only imagine what the kids whenever they
end up back in school are gonna be told
um and this is only one of the ways it's
not the only way that self-loathing is
instilled
and it's not like you escape the
self-loathing by being
another race because that that that's
not gonna happen either
boys of all races are told that they're
toxic
that they're infected with toxic
masculinity that their masculinity is
yet another thing that has to be purged
and deconstructed and destroyed so
uh think about already now now imagine a
a white boy
being subjected to this kind of thing in
school
they're they're just toxic down the line
toxic whiteness toxic
masculinity everything about them
they're told has to be deconstructed
they should hate
everything about themselves and for
girls
um it's it's the same though it's not
quite as explicit
now with boys in our culture they are
explicitly told
to hate themselves girls not quite as
explicit but they're still the same kind
of message
a girl who finds quote traditional
femininity appealing who dreams more of
being a mother and a wife than say a
businesswoman
is told to reject that to hate it boys
and girls together are taught to be
suspicious of their parents their
families their history
they're taught to hate their country
they're taught to hate everyone who came
before them all of those
ignorant bigots who made them and raised
them
and it's not like the message to
non-white people and non-white kids is
positive either
because they're taught that they're
victims and that they will never not be
victims
that they need to be rescued that
they're helpless
there's a lot of self-loathing that
comes with that as well
so just think about this think about
what we're doing
see we thought that the problem was the
opposite right this is the way that
we've talked about it for so long
we thought that self-love and and
self-esteem were being overemphasized
and they are
but the self-love that kids are
conditioned into
is very specific and very shallow and
weird and backwards
so they're taught to embrace their vices
their sins they're taught to define
themselves by their sexual proclivities
they're taught to
reject their biological sex and invent
some new kind of
gender for themselves but underneath all
of that
underneath all that when you get down to
the bottom of it all
we are not turning kids into
overconfident narcissist not at
all we may be turning them into
narcissists
in a certain way because anyone who's
who's focused intensely on themselves
and can't see outside of their own
interests
can't think about anything other than
themselves that's a narcissist
but just because you're thinking about
yourself and you're focused intensely on
yourself doesn't mean it's in a positive
way
so we may be turning kids into
narcissists in a certain way but
self-loathing ones
self-loathing narcissists we live in a
culture of self-loathing narcissists
we're raising generations of
self-loathing narcissists
because that's the message that's being
sent at the deepest level right
hate yourself hate who you really are
reject it all if you're a white
boy going to school and and uh totally
exposed to modern culture
especially if you don't have a family if
you don't have parents
they're going to insulate you to some
extent from that then forget about it
it's nothing but self-loathing
all the way down the line but it's not
just white boys it's
everyone to some extent
hate who you really are reject it be
something else
be someone else be who we want you to be
who we think you should be not who you
actually
are and then we wonder
we wonder why our kids are depressed and
suicidal
well it's no mystery it really isn't
let's get to our five headlines
i think many of us still think that uh
there are some problems that
you might experience like hair loss that
can't be solved and if that's happening
to you there's nothing you can do about
it well that's not the case
you know 80 million men and women in
this year in the u.s experience
thinning hair yet it's still not openly
talked about which can make going
through it feel scary and stressful and
that adds to the problem
uh millions of americans experience
thinning hair it's it's common it's
normal but again it's not something that
we're talking about and it makes a lot
harder
and it also means that people might not
find out about something like neutrophil
neutrophil is formulated with potent
botanicals to help you grow hair as
strong as you are and it's physician
formulated to be 100 percent
drug free on top of thicker stronger
hair without lasers or chemicals
neutrophils ingredients may also get you
helping get a handle on better sleep
stress response skin nails libido
visit nutrafall.com and take their hair
wellness quiz for customized product
recommendations that put the power to
grow thicker
stronger hair back into your hands does
it work
yes in clinical studies neutral fall
uses users saw thicker stronger hair
growth with less shedding
in three to six months whether you're
experiencing thinning or not you deserve
hair as strong as you are neutral fall
can help you achieve your best hair
growth
naturally and you've got to try this out
you can grow thicker stronger hair
and support our show by going to
nutrafall.com and use promo code walsh
to get 20
off your first subscription that's their
best offer available
anywhere you can get that right now plus
free shipping on every order
get 20 off at nutrafall.com codewalsh
that's their best offer anywhere again
20 off nutrafall.com
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-dot-com promo
code walsh
for hair as strong as you are before we
really get into the headlines here this
is one that i didn't have
planned i didn't have written on my my
sheet of headlines because i just saw it
right before we went on the air
rush limbaugh has died at the age of
70 from uh from lung cancer it feels
sudden
somehow it somehow it still feels sudden
even though
we knew for months now that he'd been
diagnosed and he'd and he talked about
it openly
um still in some way
to me anyway it feels sudden and i guess
that's
the way it goes when you have a man of
such consequence
a true legend and pioneer and icon who
dies
someone who is really in every sense
irreplaceable
when they die and leave behind a hole
that that cannot really be
be filled he was a man of consequence
and no matter how you feel about his
politics you should be able to respect
that at least
i know that's not the way it goes now in
our culture you know we don't we don't
admire and respect
great men and women but we should even
if you disagree
with them um to be a true original
which he was in a world of copycats and
he spawned a whole generation
of copycats you know um one other thing
i want to say here is that
obviously that you've got these vile
ghouls
online who are already celebrating his
death
and dancing on his grave and all of that
and we we knew that was going to happen
um but i what i what i really
wish we wouldn't do as conservatives and
especially conservative media is amplify
that because
you know the trolls the reason that
they're doing that is because they want
attention so let's not give them
that attention that's what i would
rather do i'm not going to sit here and
read oh you're not going to believe what
this
twitter user said about wrestling but
i'm not going to do that because that's
what they want
that's what they would want me to do
it's what they want all of us to do
the other thing about rush limbaugh that
i that i've been thinking about even
before
this news is that he
faced his own mortality and his own
death with courage and dignity
another thing you should be able to
respect regardless of politics
he talked about it openly and he he
wasn't he wasn't
uh especially his one of his last shows
or before christmas and he was uh and he
was
talking about it was clear that he was
he wasn't trying to delude himself
into thinking that you know everything
is going to be okay he knew the end was
coming he just didn't know exactly when
but he knew it was coming
and he faced that with courage and
dignity and that's again not something
that you can say about everybody
and i suspect that a lot of the trolls
who are dancing on his grave
and having a good laugh when their time
comes they will not face it with the
same courage and dignity
that uh that rush limbaugh faces on
something to think about
before you if you're considering
celebrating anybody's death or laughing
about it like it's a joke
you know we're all mortal we're all
going to join rush limbaugh and every
other
all the other billions of people who
have died sooner rather than later we'll
all join them
we all live short lives we're mortal and
that's the lot
that we have been given as mortal beings
so maybe maybe
maybe hold off on the laughter a little
bit because your your turn is coming
all of us it is uh but just another
thing to admire about rush limbaugh that
he was able to do that
um and
he's uh again a legend
icon um there'll be a lot of time to
sort of talk about and parse out and
analyze his his influence which was
immense and in a lot of ways
incalculable but for now what i'll say
is rest and peace to rush limbaugh
and uh prayers prayers for his family
you know i have to say i'm a little bit
of a hypocrite
because i have been criticizing
you know the nashville city government
here for for being completely unprepared
for their lack of winter weather
preparedness as we go into like day
three and
i haven't seen a plow touch any road um
but
we're not much better you know i guess i
discovered i
we also were not prepared and that's why
yesterday i took my kids out to go
sledding at the park
and uh we didn't have any sleds we had
no sleds for them and so we had to take
the lids from you know the big plastic
storage bins that you put stuff in
so we took the lids from big plastic
storage bins
and that's what they were sledding on
plastic lids
down at the park so that's all we had we
all had for that we really we couldn't
get to
walmart to get them new ones and even if
we did they'd probably all be out anyway
but then we go down to the park and of
course
you know of course a bunch of other kids
there and all the kids have the fanciest
sleds you've ever seen in your life
bunch so you know nobody around here has
a shovel or
salt for their sidewalk but they do have
seventy dollar sleds
and i had a lot of i have to say i was
experiencing a lot of sled envy and a
lot of sled
shame at the same time my kids not so
much they were they were having a grand
old time on their
lids so that's good kids are very simple
which is nice
uh okay number one this to me is a
pretty big deal
reading from the national review a
column by andrew mccarthy it says a few
days ago the new york times quietly
updated its report published over a
month earlier asserting that
capital police officer brian siknik had
been killed by being struck with a fire
extinguisher during the january 6 riot
according to the update this is the new
york times this is their update
new information has emerged regarding
the death of capitol police officer
brian siknik that questions the initial
cause of death
provided by officials close to the
capitol police
as i detailed in a column last week
mccarthy says what the times calls new
information actually began emerging the
same day the paper filed its january 8th
report
then the column goes on to say that
their reports there were reports as
early as january 8th
so that is less than two days afterwards
saying that siknik may have died of a
stroke
and as no evidence has emerged for any
other
theory the stroke idea seems extremely
credible at this point
which means that his death
didn't necessarily have any connection
to the riot whatsoever
in fact it seems to me again because
there's there's no ev there's no other
evidence for anything
we have the reports initially saying it
was a stroke uh but
that hasn't been confirmed yet as far as
i'm aware and we were never told
anything officially about the medical
exam or the autopsy report
um but if he was
beat to death bludgeoned to death at
this point you would expect there to be
some kind of evidence for it
some sort of arrest that had been made
and that hasn't happened
so this seems very credible that it was
a stroke
was it a stroke somehow connected to the
riot did the riot trigger
something did he i mean it's possible
it's also very possible that it's a
coincidence that it there
was riot and then he happened to suffer
this medical emergency after the fact
but you have to you have to ask yourself
um during the whole course of the blm
riots over the
over the summer hundreds of cities
uh was there was there ever during all
of that
did any police officer in
you know after a riot had occurred maybe
at his home or or back um at the station
suffer a medical emergency and die
a stroke a heart attack something like
that
did that happen well we don't know i
mean it could have easily happened the
point is it would not have been reported
it wouldn't have made the news but it
easily could have happened
was there there was rioting in portland
for months
during the whole course of all that
writing in portland did any police
officer die
of anything seems very likely i don't
know it seems likely
but it wouldn't be reported that's the
difference
and if the media did report it they
certainly wouldn't assume that there's a
connection and report it
as a connection if a portland police
officer
went home and eight hours after he was
on duty dealing with a riot he he died
of a stroke
the media would not report it as
connected to the riots
and we all know that
but what we've seen here the way that um
the democrat party has
exploited this man's death and lied
about it
because let's be real about this this
fire extinguisher story this
this was a lie it was a fabrication i
don't know who originally fabricated it
but it was a fabrication
because it just didn't happen it's not
like
something similar happened and it was
misinterpreted it doesn't it's
nothing like that happened to officer
brian sicknick so
uh this appears to be a total
fabrication total lie we don't really
know
where it originated i don't think it
originated with the new york times maybe
it did
but we don't know but what they've done
here by exploiting this man's death and
lying about it
is is one of the most craven
things we've seen from the democrat
party and
and i realized what a statement that is
but i want to emphasize
how despicable this really has been and
it only shows again
why you you know i don't know how many
times we have to see this before people
before it really sinks in with all of us
you cannot take the mainstream media
narrative at face value
ever okay
anytime there's a report about anything
especially if it's something that has
political significance
the democrat party is using uh to you
know
push some sort of agenda of theirs any
time that happens whatever the report is
you have to be skeptical
and there were signs early on like the
way that this was reported
from the very beginning because it is
you know we're also at a disadvantage
none of us were there we if we don't
have our own sources and people on the
ground telling us then
how are we supposed to know what
happened we have to you know where are
we supposed to get our information and
that's part of the problem but
there were signs early on to be
skeptical of this
the way it was reported yeah the media
was saying that maybe there was a fire
extinguisher we were hearing something
about maybe he was hit over the head or
whatever but if you looked at the way it
was reported
it was framed and kind of it was framed
in an oddly passive
sort of way where they were telling us
that officer siknik was engaging with
rioters and then and then you know and
suffered an injury and then later died
and it was just kind of
it wasn't exactly being reported that he
had been beat to death right there
during the riot there was this little
bit of
there was there was clear uncertainty
enough to make you stop and go wait wait
a second what exactly happened here
never take the mainstream media
narrative face value always be skeptical
um you can't go wrong right there's no
there's no real disadvantage to just
being skeptical
it doesn't mean you automatically
disbelieve every single thing you're
told by the mainstream media but
always skeptical especially when there's
political significance
okay from the daily wire it says in a
never-before-seen 1992 home video dylan
farrow the adopted daughter of
woody allen and mia ferro is heard as a
seven-year-old
telling her mother that allen touched
her private parts
telling her this allen told her
allegedly do not move i have to do this
the young girl then pointlessly pointly
tells her mother
i didn't want him to do it mama i didn't
like it
the video was featured in a new
four-part hbo documentary series about
the oscar-winning director
titled allen vs pharaoh that premieres
sunday on hbo
the series will feature recordings that
mia secretly made of her phone
conversations with alan including one in
which
she tells him that dylan is not all
right after the alleged incident
uh mia farrow and allen who had been
together since 1979 split after she
found out that he was having an affair
with her adopted daughter
suny previn at the time allen was 55 and
suny previn
was uh 21. and then it goes into
if you want to watch this documentary it
goes into great detail about woody allen
you know
it's pretty clear to me like of course
we got to attach allegedly to all these
clams and everything and um
regardless though i mean this is a guy
55 years old
marries his girlfriend's adopted
daughter
who's 34 years younger than him
that's enough right there to know this
guy is a degenerate creepy freak
already from that
and then you add in these claim these uh
the allegations
i personally find them quite credible
given what we know about
woody allen but think about all the
hollywood a-listers that have worked
with this guy
almost everyone in hollywood has almost
all the big names have at some point
worked on a woody allen project
and yet these people will still lecture
us
and even while the me even even once me
too happened and during the
the metoo hysteria woody allen was still
putting movies out
and a lot of the me too champions were
still starring in them
number three claudia conway um the
daughter of kellyanne
conway and george conway auditioned on
american idol a couple nights ago
now american idol came in for some
criticism by people calling this
exploitative and gross
to bring this girl in as fauna for
tabloids to bring attention to the show
exploiting her troubled situation
and i guess um the question of whether
it's
exploitative to have claudia conway on
american idol it certainly seems
exploitative to me
but it really depends on on whether
claudia conway is actually a burgeoning
pop star
i mean if she really is massively
talented as a singer then maybe you
can't blame them for for bringing her on
if she's actually that good but if she's
not
then you have to ask why she made the
show at all and i know that they do
bring on some bad singers on purpose so
that everyone can
laugh at them but then you have to ask
why did they pick her
that would seem especially exploitative
if she's not a very good singer
and she wants to be an american idol and
she's only famous because of this
deeply troubled disordered
family dysfunction that she's a part of
and you bring her on the show
well that's that's extremely
exploitative isn't it so that's what it
really comes down to for me
is she a good singer or not and this is
not to make fun of her or anything but
that's i i think that's how you can tell
if if this is blatant exploitation
or not and so let's um she did the
audition a couple
nights ago and let's let's take a listen
[Music]
it is the last time that we might
be exactly like we were
before
[Music]
yeah um yes it was exploitation
it was it was exploitation and i don't
mean this this is not about
mocking this girl who i feel bad for
this
she didn't ask to be a part of this and
um
well she may have asked to be a part of
it she has to be a part of american idol
and and she has been
on social media bringing attention to
herself but she's a kid
you know we the kids don't know any
better
um what she didn't ask for is to be in
this deeply dysfunctional family
situation
with a mother and father apparently seem
to hate each other and
are pretty public about it um
or at least at least i would say it
seems that the father hates the mother
and is pretty public about that
um but any case yeah this is
claudia conway is not going to be a pop
star i think we could tell from that
she's a better singer she's a fine
singer she's a better singer than i am
she's got a better shot at pop stardom
than i do but even so she's not going to
be a pop star
and they brought her on anyway and so
yes
confirmed exploitation number four uh
here's some bad news
from jen pasagi listen i think one
point the europeans would like to better
understand it what he means with foreign
policy
for the middle class does it mean to
uphold donald trump's tariffs like
in the case of aluminum from the uae
this
the biden administration used the same
reasoning as the trump administration
i can assure you that the president this
president does not have
is not looking to the last presidency as
the model for his foreign policy
moving forward uh president biden has
been working
in the global arena for decades and what
he means
by foreign policy for the middle class
is
ensuring that our team working on
economic issues our team working on
national security issues
our teams thinking about how policies
impact the american people
are talking and that we make decisions
and make policies through that prism
we are certainly reviewing a range of
tariffs that have been put in place by
the past administration i don't have any
updates on that for you
but what the president is speaking to is
the importance of
contemplating integrating our domestic
and national security teams and the
policy making and the process that
they go through and his view that we are
stronger globally
if we take care of our house here at
home uh so that is part of his objective
as well
well that is bad news trump is not a
model for their foreign policy
why not why
i think if he's a model for anything
it's actually foreign policy
but i think there are a lot of aspects
of donald trump that you wouldn't want
to
model yourself after or your
presidential administration after
but um foreign policy absolutely
we went through four years without a new
war peace deals in the middle east
that's pretty damn successful
he one thing i think you can't deny is
that he is the most successful
foreign policy president that we've had
in generations
um and it's it's a sad statement though
right
because the the main thing that makes
him such a great foreign policy
president and makes him so successful is
simply that he didn't start any wars and
so
it's unfortunate that the bar is that
low that all you have to do as a
president is not
start a disastrous war that claims
thousands of lives and
billions or trillions of dollars like
that's all you have to do is not start a
war
but that's where we are and uh and he
and he did get over that bar he cleared
that bar quite easily
and i think he deserves a lot of credit
for that so yes i
i would like to see i would like to see
the trump foreign policy
emulated but we won't now we're to go
back to the more traditional
uh foreign policy which means droning
random villages overseas starting wars
trying to spread democracy to people who
have no
interest in democracy whatsoever that's
what we're going to get from
from joe biden and also another another
thing from
jen saki i want to play for you more
more bad news i'm afraid
she was asked by someone on twitter how
she plans to help
small businesses does uh or or rather
how does biden plan to
to help small businesses does the
administration have a plan in place what
are they going to do for all these small
businesses that have been
devastated by the lockdowns and here is
her answer
what is president biden doing for my
small business first and foremost he
nominated a woman to lead the small
business administration who
formerly worked there second thing is he
signed an executive order to make it
easier for
minority-owned small businesses to get
access to the funding
that they need and third is that in the
american rescue plan
there's currently about 60 billion
dollars to help
a range of small small businesses get
access to additional funds
so did you get that the first two things
number one and two
first thing he nominated a woman and
also he's going to help minority
businesses great well so what
so you're a white male business owner
guess you're out of luck
all business owners are really out of
luck when it comes down to it this this
is how because
think about this was not um an
off-the-cuff
answer that jen saki gave at a press
conference
this was this was something that they
shot ahead of time
and put a little production behind and
then released
so they this this is how they presented
it on purpose
which shows how incredibly out of touch
the left is
democrat politicians are that they
actually thought the average small
business owner
would hear that answer and be happy with
it
they they really thought that the
average small business owner who
is watching their life's work fall apart
in front of them
will take solace in the fact that uh
well at least a woman was nominated
to lead the small business
administration
that's what they think they they they
don't understand
how a normal person's brain operates
that is how it operates in a rational
logical kind of way
and the rational logical conclusion is
that i don't give a damn
if you get what what gender is leading
what administration
or what agency in government what do i
care about that
these policies have destroyed my life
and my business that's what i care about
it doesn't make it any better because
there are more women in the
administration now
they do not understand that they don't
understand it they don't
they don't have brains that work that
they don't have normally functioning
brains and that's the problem
number five from the hill it says bill
gates recently said that he believes
rich nations would help the global fight
against climate change by consuming only
plant-based meat products instead of
beef
in a recent interview with technology
review gates discussed his new book
how to avoid a climate disaster and
emphasize the benefits
rich nations could produce by moving to
100 synthetic beef
he says i do think all rich countries
should move 100 synthetic beef
uh you can get used to taste difference
and the claim is they're going to make
it taste even better over time
yeah no thanks bill i don't think i
don't think i'll be doing that i don't
think i'll ever be doing that i'm going
to stick with the regular beef
and also i don't i i don't really give a
damn
about your opinion about anything
we're hearing we're hearing a lot from
bill gates these last few months
why should but no one ever stops to
explain
why we should actually care what he
thinks about anything i understand that
he's rich and he was successful with his
business
good for him but why should i care what
he thinks
about what i eat why should i care what
he thinks about
the virus mitigation strategies what
should i care what he thinks about the
climate
that's the part that's always left out
when bill gates is brought in for an
interview or bill gates sits down for a
written interview
or they write another article about what
bill gates thinks
nobody ever stops and says oh by the way
here's why you should care
what this guy says until they explain it
i'm going to continue not caring
unless they can give me some really good
reason why i should
and you know as far as bill gates's own
diet i have no idea he might be a
vegetarian himself
but i would not be surprised at all if
that guy's eating you know six
hamburgers a day
while telling the rest of us that we're
gonna have to move to the plant-based
stuff and
you know we'll get used to the taste
you'll get used to the taste i will i'm
not gonna worry about that because i'm
bill gates but but you
you know you'll figure it out what do
you need good taste for
why do you need good food you don't need
that
just another basic joy basic pleasure in
life that you don't need
i mean i'll have all the joys and
pleasures for myself but you don't need
it
that's the attitude shut up bill shut up
that's my that would be my response
let's go to uh read in the comments now
some of the comments under the show on
youtube
from yesterday and if you want me to
read your comment all you have to do is
uh
is leave one and that's that's a good
that's a good at least at least put you
in the running you can't win if you
don't play as they say
this is from walt g he says a little
thought experiment an alien civilization
has the technology to
to detect life on earth the ability to
travel light years using incredibly
advanced technology
they overcome all of these obstacles
that we still can't fathom
they achieve these things get here and
crash
yeah i do i do think about that when we
hear about the
documents
outlining all of the ufo material that
the pentagon has tested and
again of course ufo doesn't when the
when the pentagon talks about ufo or i
guess now the
word they use is uap unidentified aerial
phenomenon
they're not saying that it's a space
alien they're they're simply saying they
can't identify they don't know what it
is
and we talked about yesterday the
hundreds of
pages of documents that they released
freedom of information act request
talking about the unidentified
flying objects they recovered and tested
and
apparently allegedly some of this stuff
has
material that functions in a way that is
unknown
to uh to mankind as far as we know metal
that can be bent
you know it's basically indestructible
but it can be bent in all these
different shapes and then
and then we'll snap back into its
original shape that kind of thing
and yeah i love these stories i do find
them very interesting
i do think we should at least entertain
the idea that that maybe they are
extraterrestrial in origin
but then i also think man
all of these super advanced
civilizations coming here and then they
crash
that's there's something about that
there seems to be a little bit of a
disconnect i don't know
aaron peacock says grown men that take
baths
also sit down when they pee i agree
aaron i
absolutely agree i'm very anti-bath
matthew
uh milscale says matt i am single right
now and i can tell you that it's awful
trying to find someone i thought being
able to go to college would be my chance
to meet someone but instead i get to
spend my time
behind a computer screen yeah i don't i
don't envy you for that at all
um and i feel i i do i feel terrible for
for people that are in this situation
especially you know maybe like you
you're supposed to
have your first year at college looking
forward to meeting people
and now you're just sitting behind a
computer screen
um but it kind of it
it kind of relates back to the meat
thing from bill gates
where he says yeah yeah hamburgers and
meat tastes good it's a little joy that
that that you have in your life but you
don't need that we could take that we
could take another little joy away from
you
and the people that have engineered the
lockdowns and push them and keep them in
place
they have the same attitude about
little little joys little human things
like going out and meeting people
they say you don't really need that you
can survive in your house
until you can't anymore but until then
you can survive
you'll have all the food food doesn't
even need to taste good
see the elites as far as they're
concerned
if they simply keep you alive then
they've done
their job as long as you're still alive
then you have nothing to complain about
while they again enjoy all of the
pleasures and everything that life has
to offer
they also have not been staying home
these people bill gates have been flying
all over the place
doing interviews you know they get
they get they they're they're still
going to work they're having press
conferences
in fact they're more active than they've
ever been but you don't need that
uh little things like companionship who
needs that
well in fact everyone does people need
that human beings need companionship
it is that is an actual human need
dano says hey matt you cancelling your
own fan followers gives me anxiety
please don't cancel me
losing trump and losing my ability to
watch your show will destroy my life
well thano you know when you
beg to be canceled that's only a recipe
for getting canceled and banned from the
show
so you're gone but thanks anyway
for listening and commenting for your
final time
i'm not big on new year's resolutions
because i think that if there's
something that you
actually intend to do then you're not
going to save it for some moment
well i'm going to start doing it on the
new year no if you want to do something
if you want to improve your life you
could start right now
and so we don't need to call this a new
year's resolution how about a right now
resolution one of them
is to to learn to grow your um
your knowledge to become a more
well-rounded person this is a process we
should always
be um be you know involved in
because learning is not something that
you simply do at school it's something
you should be doing every single day and
that's why
i am a big fan of great courses have
been for a long time and i really love
their newest offer which is the great
courses plus with the great courses plus
you have unlimited access to thousands
of video and audio lectures on hundreds
of fascinating topics
um some of the topics i i've i've list
i've taken great courses
um classes on you know history
biblical history american history
ancient history
science psychology pretty much anything
you could you could possibly have
whatever the subject is that you that
you're interested in or you think you
might be interested in
they've probably got a course on it plus
with the great courses plus
app you're free to watch listen and
learn on any device at any time
it's very easy to do no matter where you
are in the world the courses are taught
by the best professors and top
experts in their fields and it's all all
the material is extensively vetted in
research so this is not like
going on wikipedia to learn something
this is really learning it i'm so glad i
found a more productive way to spend my
time and i want you
to do the same with the great courses
plus get started with a free month of
unlimited access just visit my special
url here it is
the great courses plus walsh that's a
whole month to learn
anything you want for free so sign up
now i really i can't urge you enough to
do it
you got to check it out remember
thegreatcoursesplus.com
walsh and one other thing uh to mention
here
as i'm sure you know actress gina carono
carano that is has been
making her way through the news cycle
recently she was cancelled for
for being a conservative that's the real
reason they come up with other excuses
for but the real
her real offense is that she's a a
conservative actress
very successful she was on the hit
disney plus show the mandalorian
now she's been dropped because of um
because of the cancel culture mob
well we the daily wire we've been
talking about fighting back not not
and not always playing defense but
playing offense too and fighting back
and that's why we just announced a movie
deal with gina that's correct she'll be
developing producing and starring in an
upcoming film that will be released
exclusively to daily wire members
we've all said it conservatives need to
do more than complain and critique we
need to actually
stop running away from the culture and
start creating culture ourselves and
that's what we're doing
and we're going up against disney plus
they've got eight billion dollars to
spend we have you that's
that's our secret weapon so join us
today in the fight to take back our
culture go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code gina that's
g-i-n-a to get 25
off your membership today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
it's really impossible to remember all
of the fake and frivolous controversies
that the internet has given us
that's part of the fake and frivolous
package i suppose they're all so
forgettable but one such controversy has
uh stood out and will be remembered at
least by me
that's the controversy surrounding the
man who is known now as
being dead now some background john
roderick is a musician
podcast host who became infamous on
twitter last month
after he tweeted out a thread detailing
his daughter's experience with a can
opener
now in a long very unnecessarily long
story he explained that his daughter
wanted to open a can of beans
but rather than do it for her he he had
he
had her figure it out for herself as a
kind of teaching
opportunity and he says it took her
hours hours
trying to open the can before she
finally did it and he posted this as
sort of a congratulations to himself
for being a good dad but the world and
twitter
didn't see it that way the thread went
viral people were
outraged they accused him of abuse
psychological abuse emotional abuse
physical abuse
they said that he was starving his
daughter they said he's a horrible
person etc and so forth
then they started digging up his old
tweets of course and next thing you know
he's
not only a bad father abusive but racist
too so he's racist and abusive
all this stuff happened and eventually
he apologized and deactivated his
account but it was too late
meanwhile back in realityville
it's obvious that the story was an
exaggeration the girl was not working
on a can of beans for hours give me a
break and even if she was
it's not abuse presumably she's not
malnourished
he is feeding her he never said that her
continued access to food was predicated
on her ability to get the can open he
didn't say that so even if he was being
a jerk
about the can whatever calling that
abuse is insane
and look i i have never
been in a situation where my kids were
trying to open a can for six hours so
i've never done that but all of us as
parents we have moments where our kids
ask us to do something and uh and
we could do it for them it would be very
easy for us to do but for whatever
reason
we just don't feel like doing it and so
we say no look you've figured that out
for yourself i'm not doing it
so all parents have moments like that
and it's good to have moments like that
it's good for the for the kid to have to
figure something out
um six hours opening a can is a little
bit excessive
but even so so there was no abuse here
uh and being dad's real crime if he
committed one was in being a tool who
tries to
you know brag about his own excellent
parenting on the internet
or what he thinks is excellent parenting
and if that's
the crime then that's the one he
committed but that doesn't make him a
child abuser right
or or so i thought an update on this
story from reason written by lenore
scanase it says roderick recently
divulged a new wrinkle in the story
which makes it clear that it was not
just an online kerfuffle
for his afternoon of bean withholding
roderick actually earned a visit from
the child protective services
in roderick on the line his weekly
podcast with merlin mann
roderick said a dozen people reported me
to cps and they were obligated to come
interview my family and interrogate my
daughter
thankfully the cps visit went well they
were wonderful said roderick and they
were just doing their jobs
apparently one investigator told
roderick's daughter for about an hour or
rather
spoke to roderick's daughter for about
an hour privately asking questions like
what do you like about your dad and what
do you not like about your dad
roderick's daughter told him about this
afterward turns out she doesn't like the
fact that he gets tired of playing
legos faster than he than she does
okay so that's that's a report from
reason child protective services
because he made his daughter open a can
of beans on her own
this is the kind of thing that keeps
parents up at night right this this
right here not because we've
we have similar family drama involving
cans of beans
and not because we're abusive but
because cps can be summoned to our homes
very easily and for the most trivial of
reasons and once they show up
your parental rights are on the line of
course
they're not suspended now so cps does
not have the right to enter your home
without permission
or to speak to your your child without
permission and that's something that
parents
i think a lot of parents don't realize
and um
cps i think counts on parents not
realizing that and they show up and
knock on the door and they say can we
come in can we talk to your kid
and parents because they are scared and
and they feel like their backs against
the wall now they'll say sure come in
and
you don't have to do that and it's a
mistake
to let cps in in that situation because
think about it they're
according to um john roderick they're
sitting down they're talking to her
his daughter for an hour saying things
like what do you
these are fishing leading kinds of
questions
what do you not like about your dad
i mean who knows what kind of thing a
kid will say in response to that
kids are imaginative kids that
they don't really understand what the
consequences are they don't really know
what's going on
a kid could be you know you could cps
could come in at a moment when the child
is angry at the parent not because
they're being abused but because kids
get angry about you know not being
allowed to watch tv when they want to or
something
and who knows what they'll say so the
minute you say sure sit down and talk to
my kid for an hour
that could go anywhere i mean that could
be the last time you see your kid for a
long time
depending on how that goes um
but even if you don't let the cps in
they can they can
go and they're not going to leave you
alone after that they can go get a court
order
they can continue harassing if they
choose once cps is in your life
it can be very difficult to get them out
and just the simple
fact that they showed up at your door
carries a stigma that may never go away
even if again you're totally innocent as
the article in reason lays out the
system is
broken anyone can report abuse they can
do it anonymously they can do it as many
times as they want and all reports are
investigated no matter how obviously
frivolous they are
um this was um this was a report based
on a publicly available internet post
okay the people calling cps on bean dad
they were doing it based on a tweet
there is no good reason for the
government to respond to that at all
if we allow just a little bit of
judgment and discretion
then cps could have looked at the report
looked at the tweet in question and said
never mind this is absurd
oh that's what you're calling about that
what
no we're not gonna we're not gonna go
knock on the guy's door
but instead everything these days
especially in government
operates according to the zero tolerance
policy the
zero tolerance sort of philosophy and
what that means is that all situations
will be treated
exactly the same no discernment no
discretion no
human judgment will enter the equation
at all we are we are to act as robots
um according to the programming
the reason article references a report
in the new york daily news that's very
relevant here it says quote
over the past 40 years more and more
people have been calling the child abuse
hotlines
not because there's so much child abuse
going on but because they've been
conditioned to report
almost anything a kid with a scrape a
kid walking the dog
as possible abuse or neglect better safe
than sorry
but how safe how sorry according to one
estimate more than half of all
african-american children 53 will be
visited by child protective services at
some point their childhood that compared
to 37 percent of all children
which is already outrageous 37 37
of all children sounds
enormously high um i i i almost have to
doubt that it could pot 37
maybe that is as bad as it's gotten all
told it says 7.8 million kids get
reported to child protective services
each year and that is literally seven
million kids too many
the mind-bogglingly vast majority of
calls turn out to be to not be cases of
abuse or neglect at all
while tragically child abuse and neglect
deaths do occur
these cases represent two out of every
one hundred
thousand hotline calls two out of one
hundred and thousand
um and as the number of calls has gone
up in the last few two decades the
number of deaths has not gone down
that's right abuse deaths increased
possibly because caseworkers are
stretched so thin
the important thing to remember here is
that all of these millions of frivolous
child abuse reports and investigations
are not
victimless it's not like nobody is hurt
by just checking on the claim
right better safe than sorry no that's
that's not always
the case but it's a frivolous child
abuse
claim or or report
and then this innocent parent ends up in
the crosshairs
of cps and their parental rights are on
the line
and there they could possibly lose their
parental rights and lose their children
even though they didn't do anything
wrong that is not better safe than sorry
lots of families are hurt destroyed
ripped apart
once the parents become officially
suspected child abusers
that's what happens the system is indeed
broken
fixing it will be complicated work but
one thing that's needed in order to fix
it is a return to
situational judgment discretion
not treating everything the same as
everything else
not all child abuse reports are made are
are created equal they're not all the
same
okay a kid goes to school and he's
got you know he's got very suspicious
looking bruij
bruises or he looks to be malnourished
or something like that that
you know that's clearly you you call cps
for that
but someone sends writes a tweet about
their kid opening a can of beans
or you see an eight-year-old that was
allowed to go down to the playground
you know 100 yards from the house by
himself
walk the dog down the street he's got a
scrape on his knee no
those are not the same so this is one
thing
situational judgment discretion
um letting human beings discern
and make judgments based on based on
that
not all child abuse reports are created
equal the bean dad case shows that as so
many other cases show that as well
and that's why the people who reported
being dead are
officially canceled and that's going to
do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day stay safe out
there
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show texas freezes as the
power grid
buckles and the washington post worries
that conservatives are complaining too
much
about cancel culture so you're cancelled
that's today on the ben shapiro show
tune in